hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant game from round two of this
year's video World Cup it is the uh the
most requested game in the comments from
my previous video the Magnus Carlsen
versus 11 panzalaya game uh it is a
French Grand Master Maxim Lagarde versus
pragnaranda and uh even though uh
gookish just broke into the top 10 I
don't know if you guys have heard he
broke um he's now uh he's now less than
one point away from overtaking rifanatan
Anand in the uh in the top 10 not even
one point like 0.6 points he overtook
Rapport who is now number 11 and
although that is a very very impressive
this is the game you guys requested I
was planning on showing the gookers game
but after seeing this one I just
couldn't
um maybe I'll show it tomorrow but for
now we absolutely must see this one but
Prague also doing incredibly well uh
he's just uh like 27 20 now also really
climbing rapidly uh we're gonna discuss
that after we check out the game because
this is just I mean it it's like a
modern a modern Immortal or something I
don't know what code you guys can figure
it out I'm just here to show you the
moves so here uh Maxim Lagarde has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to B5 so a normal real Lopez
um uh you you probably don't expect you
know fireworks here but Prague goes for
Knight G2 E7 the causio defense and
something you don't see at the absolute
top level at least not very often we
have Knight to C3 Knight to G6 and now
Pawn to D4 and usually e captures on D4
is played but proc plays Knight captures
on the form at the top level uh not
really not really a weapon one would use
does use it he he has employed it three
times but there is a game where Arjun
negasi uh used it against the
vishwanathan himself but Anand won that
game it was last year in the European
Club cup uh so let's see what uh Prague
found is an improvement Knight captures
on D4 e captures and queen captures on
D4 now hindering the development of the
dark Square Bishop as the G7 pod would
hang so C6 chasing away the bishop with
Bishop to E2 and now Queen to B6 Prague
offers a queen trade uh and Maxime
declines Queen to D3 and now there is a
game where Castle who's played also
Queen to G3 is a known move uh but
Prague plays the immediate uh sorry
Maxim plays a prophet Bishop D7 but
Maxine plays a pawn to F4 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game
sorry about that forgot to include the
progress Bishop D7 there uh so okay uh
Bishop D7 uh F4 and now Castles by
Prague we have Pawn to H4 by Maxine uh
preparing to play point H5 to kick away
the Knight and while Prague could play
Bishop captures an H4 with check he
decides against it because after Bishop
captures in G3 as the pawn is defended
the bishop moves back uh you gave Maxim
the open H file for The Rook could be a
little bit dangerous so the first
product plays Pawn to D5 he wants to
give his a light Square Bishop into the
game uh and now uh okay you could play
captures on D5 sure but then Bishop
captures an H4 uh captures on H4 with
check G3 and now Bishop to F6 let's say
Pawn to D6 and now Bishop to E6 uh
Prague would be very happy with this to
get his uh Bishops into the game and now
okay this uh that does look all that
impressive as uh you can't really kick
away that knight from G6 if you push F5
even if you play something like I don't
know how we do would even even push up
five uh um because you would close down
your diagonal so it doesn't really make
sense you will not be able to attack so
instead after D5 we have pawned the H5
right away and here come as the uh the
action we have uh uh he D captures on e4
and now we have Queen to G3 now the
Knight cannot move otherwise you you
might have some problems here but he
does play Knight to H for him he says I
don't mind uh if you play Pawn to H6 it
doesn't really work due to Knight to F5
attacking the queen defending against
Checkmate and also preparing the capture
on H6 so how do you react to Knight to
H4 uh you can't even play something like
Bishop to E3 even though you know you
don't necessarily want to react to this
but then just Queen captures and beat
you so there's no good move that white
can play here at uh to play a useful
move even so he has to accept the
challenge and he plays Rook captures on
H4 now he would very much enjoy it if
Prague just captures The Rook he
captures with the queen but he goes
Queen to G1 check first Maxim blocks
with Bishop to F1 and now comes Pawn to
E3 this is a beautiful beautiful move
the only move that gives the advantage
the Prague Pawn to E2 and now how do you
defend it's uh not easy and The Rook
here is still being attacked but you
don't have time to deal with the Rook
Knights the D1 you have to go after the
pawn here and you can't just capture it
um yes okay you're attacking it twice
but then uh Bishop will capture an H4 or
if or even if Bishop captures an E3 then
Bishop captures an H4 and you have
problems here you cannot capture because
Queen captures comes with check and if
Bishop captures and G1 Bishop captures
and G3 comes with check and now uh
Black's position is much much better
Bishop F2 Bishop captures on F4 and you
are just
um uh up upon but also your position is
that much better no no not just up a
point also of the exchange you have two
Rooks and two Bishops for a rook uh two
Bishops and the Knight so of course
completely winning so instead after E3
we have Knight to D1 going after the
pawn this way and now Rook to E8 another
beautiful quiet move by Prague again not
rushing with Bishop captures on H4 and
how do you react to this do you have
time to save The Rook absolutely not the
problem is if you play something like
where would you even put the Rook let's
say you play Rook H2 you get checkmated
it's actually a forced Checkmate in
eight moves Bishop to B4 with check
opens up the E file for the rook and
after we play something doesn't really
matter just Pawn to E2 there's no
there's no move here you have to play
something 93 but now he captures an F1
with check you bring a Queen into the
game King to D2 as the Knight of course
cannot move you have to move the king
king to D2 now you can play Rook 38 with
checking the C to even give up one of
the Queens you don't need both of them
Knight captures Queen captures with
check King B1 and of course Bishop to F5
with check this is only one of the lines
that completely destroy White Queen D3
and now Bishop or queen captures will be
Checkmate so instead after Rook d8 Queen
sorry King the ET was played I mean just
by seeing this move you know that this
is just not gonna work out well uh and
uh okay yeah okay one thing you we could
consider is also Bishop captures on E3 I
I would want to mention that before
showing what actually happened now you
get Bishop captures on H4 and after
Queen captures Rook captures on E3 with
check Knight captures Queen captures
with check and after Bishop T2 there's
this spectacular Bishop to G4 you don't
have time to go after the Rook because
you will have to waste one move and then
you're gonna get a checkmated with Queen
to d8 so first you throw in Bishop to G4
you are threatening Checkmate now so
white will have the capture on G4 and
now Queen G1 with check and you can go
if you go Bishop to F1 then Rook to E8
will be crushing but other moves aren't
all that better if King to D2 then Queen
captures an A1 and if Now Pawn to H6 it
doesn't really matter because Queen
captures on B2 defends against Checkmate
and next Rook 38 is coming and white
gets absolutely crushed so those are the
two ideas you can't move the Rook you
can't capture the pawn that's why King
the E2 was played by Maxim uh but I mean
look at this uh we have uh Bishop D6
another a very nice move by Prague now
Bishop to C4 will be a huge problem so
upon the B3 defending against Bishop to
C4 and also maybe hoping to somehow
develop your Bishop threaten something
on G7 uh Rook a to d8 by frog
beautifully played we have Knight
captures I need three finally grabbing
that pawn and now white is uh White is
just up a piece and uh if uh White can
survive the attack then this extra
Knight will uh prove to be a lot but now
Prague finally moves the bishop but not
to where you're thinking he doesn't go
for the The Rook on H4 he plays Bishop
to F6 aligning the bishop into Rook
nicely on A1 The Rook is undefended so
even though your king is a need to you
hate your position you you can't just
allow Bishop captures anyone for nothing
it's a free free hanging Rook so Rook
the B1 and now another beautiful move
Bishop to F5 uh just uh threatening
Bishop captures on C2 which again you
cannot allow and imagine this bishop
captures on Z2 Bishop to D1 check the
Knight cannot move uh from The Rook an
E8 so here Queen to F2 was played and
interestingly uh this queen to F2 is
such a good move that there is only one
move that wins the game for Prague but
it's not easy to spot it's a brilliant
brilliant move so feel free to pause the
video and to win the game for Prague in
in a brilliant fashion while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
fun new ways to blunder your queen and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Bishop captures on H4
this is what Prague played and now you
see that you're completely completely
lost here uh the queen of course cannot
be captured if the queen is taken Bishop
to G4 is Checkmate there is no square
for the for the wild king The Rook
controls the D file Bishop controls this
diagonal and this bishop controls F3 and
delivers check on E2 so this would be
one beautiful double Bishop double Rook
Checkmate something that we don't see
very often so after Bishop captures and
H4 the only move you can play is the
capture on H4 but not just Bishop
captures and C2 attacks The Rook
threatens Bishop to D1 with check I mean
there's what do you even play here that
you can't move the bishop the bishop is
needed here to guard the Knight and E3
otherwise just Queen captures and E3
will be Checkmate uh here Queen captures
on d8 was played only move that keeps
the game going because you can and move
the Rook away from the e file and pick
up that Bishop on C2 but now you're just
down too much material and you will lose
at some point but uh you know it's
better than resigning of course there's
nothing like nothing like a good or
stubborn defense and many have fallen
victim to it so Rook capture 78 Knight
captures on C2 and now Queen to C5 again
the absolute strongest move by Prague
attacking the Knight attacking the H5
Pawn so Knights to E3 and now Rook the
E8 putting pressure on the Knight here
King F3 on pinning and now Queen to D4
not rushing for the H5 Pawn uh we have
King back to E2 and now Queen to C5
Queen F3 a king of three repeating ones
but now Prague accepts the pawn queen
captures an H5 which check G4 and queen
to H1 with check this is now only a
matter of time King to G3 rooked the E6
now going after Rook to G6 Pawn to H5 to
blast open the position uh Bishop to D2
finally the bishop gets into the game
The Rook is now also a part of of this
game but Ponte H5 with G captures and H5
Queen captures an H5 and now Rook the E1
uh Rook to G6 with check King to F2 and
now a nice Queen to age for check king
of three Queen to G3 with check King to
E4 and now Rook the D6 proc repairs a
very very nasty surprise and uh Maxime
goes for it Rook to E2 and now feel free
to pause the video for the second time
and try to find the absolute best move
for Prague it's actually a force to
Checkmate in three moves uh so have at
it
[Music]
all right
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding all of the
three checkmating Maneuvers and for
those of you who just won't enjoy the
show it is Pawn to F5 with check this is
what proc played and it was in this
position and moved 37 at the maxim
Lagarde resigned the game as there is
really nothing more to be done here uh
so the the the thing is if you capture
with the Knight then the queen gets
access to the D3 Square Queen D3
checking the E5 and queen to D5 will be
Checkmate if you don't take with the
Knight you could also capture with the
King then you just go Queen to G6
checking D5 and queen the E6 Checkmate
and of course the last option is to not
take it at all is to play King D5 but
now Queen to G6 and next move you will
either deliver Checkmate via the F6
square or the E6 Square all depending on
what uh what the white plays like if
white plays something weird like Knight
to G4 to cover F6 then you will deliver
Queen D6 Checkmate so it's not even
possible to prolong let's say white play
spawn to B4 I mean why not just in the
E6 checkmate so uh brilliant brilliant
stuff by Prague I I don't really recall
the last time I've seen such a such a
spectacular attacking game uh both of
them I mean it requires a two to create
uh something beautiful something this
beautiful uh but after this Pawn to H4
and this position here with knights the
H4 this is just absolute complete
Madness on the board uh absolute fire
and you know just Queen G1 E3 finding
all of these beautiful silent moves I
mean look at those Bishops The Rook is
the queen and G1 uh this is uh I don't
know product has so many so many
incredible attacking successful games
that it would be a reckless to even
suggest this to be a proxy mortal game
uh but it's it's I mean it's just the
incredible game let's not over push it
uh unless you guys uh you know want to
then it's fine uh but yeah that's the
game really hope you guys enjoyed that
uh Prague just doing product things you
know as we all uh enjoy uh this is uh
what I've mentioned before the game uh
so this is currently the world's top 10
uh one uh won his game and now he's on
27 53.4 only 0.6 points uh below so if
he overtakes Anand then he will I
believe he will become India's number
one uh for the first time uh after like
37 years Anna's been on top on the
number one uh rated Indian player for 37
years I believe which is absolutely
incredible uh but the other uh other
Indians doing really really uh awesome
as well I think there are six of them in
the top top uh over 27 2750 or over 2700
So I mean incredible stuff and Prague
also Prague is
um let me just check I don't want to
trick you guys uh let me just check real
quickly Prague is yeah uh he shot up 19
places he's currently number 28 with a
live rating of 27 at 27-11 so also doing
uh incredibly incredibly well but yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to think all the games
are best Lynn Herbert uh Seth Harper
schlerter and Paul Harris for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
the other games of the video World Cup
and of course on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one pretty much
all of the comments on the previous
video where show this game show this
game show this game so there you have it
I've shown the game uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day